et mariage c'est l'union c'est l'union
qui a fait vraiment le plus de bruit cet
été Gilo Ben Affleck ils ont même été à
Paris on les a vu à Paris se sont mariés
en Géorgie sur son las vegas regardez si
mariage quoi
l'été 2022 a été marqué par un nombre
record de mariage en France et il y en a
un qui a été tout particulièrement suivi
à l'autre bout de l'Atlantique mon amour
est-ce que tu veux m'épouser non celui
de la star planétaire de la chanson
Jennifer Lopez et de son mari tout aussi
célèbre l'acteur à succès Ben Affleck
avec qui elle avait déjà eu une aventure
il y a 17 ans
[Musique]
et pour se dire oui le 20 août dernier
le couple d'une cinquantaine d'années a
mis les petits plats dans les grands du
lieu de la cérémonie au banquier façon
barbecue géant en passant par la
somptueuse robe de mariée de Gillot tout
a été minutieusement préparé
[Musique]
cette robe une magnifique traîne de 6
mètres de long signal Floren qui aurait
coûté pas moins de 400 000 dollars à la
star le rêve de toute petite fille et
encore Jennifer Lopez quand on est monde
compte pas pour agrémenter ce total look
de mariée la star à opter pour une paire
de boucles d'oreilles à 53000 dollars et
une bague serti de diamant d'une valeur
de 39000 dollars rien que ça mais ce
n'est pas tout côté convives tout gratin
d'Hollywood été là Matt Damon Jimmy
Kimmel ou encore George Clooney
cérémonie type d'elle qui s'est finie en
apothéose avec un feu d'artifice de
gigantesque
pour le plus grand plaisir de nos
oreilles pas Jennifer Lopez à son temps
de réponse
[Musique]
alors évidemment je me doute que c'est
vous vous dites 8 millions de dollars en
mariage 380000 euros pour une robe et
des boucles d'oreilles à 2 millions
d'euros non mais voilà les gens chez eux
c'est c'est en plusieurs vies tu gagnes
pas ça il a gagné son fait qu'elle le
dépensent
elle a gagné alors du divertissement à
tout le monde ça fait 20 ans c'est son
plus beau mariage ça voulait claquer 8
millions de dollars c'est son problème
elle allait pas envoyer les 7 autres
millions de dollars sur les pensées
caméléon
elle est à la tête d'une fortune de 400
millions sans compter que lui doit avoir
des sous aussi j'imagine ils vont pas
faire un mariage à 200.000 euros alors
ça paraît choquant mais ceux qui mettent
qui sont choqués excusez-moi vous êtes
contre la société capitaliste mais c'est
le principe ça n'a rien à voir
l'argent comme eux le droit j'ai encore
le droit des
pensées 8 millions de dollars
en même temps s'il te plaît j'ai pas dit
que je n'aurais jamais fait j'ai dit
j'ai le droit d'être choqué qu'on puisse
dépenser autant d'oseille dans un
mariage et j'ai excusez-moi mais à
l'époque quand quand
non non et sa femme avait dépensé à peu
près 7 millions d'euros je crois pour
leur mariage eux par contre avait invité
avait payé tous les billets d'avion
avait invité dans des dans un hôtel
magnifique tous les invités etc c'était
utilisable
alors on a compris on a compris
Jean-Pascal qui est pas choqué du tout
toi en gros ce qu'il faut c'est que tu
fais un mari beaucoup d'argent en du
monde en gros il faut partager plutôt
que se dire j'ai craqué
une boutique qui a vendu la bague
qu'elle avait envie et tant mieux ça a
fait bosser du monde c'est bien il
fallait Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui veut dire
un mot
je voulais juste faire un rappel à la
décence là juste un truc très simple non
mais très simple moi j'ai rien contre
l'organisation fastueuse les voitures
etc tout ce qui va avec par contre la
bague rien que la bague parce que c'est
un exemple parlant à 4 millions de
dollars pardon il y a des bagues
magnifiques à peut-être 200 300000
dollars qui sont déjà de ouf mais du
coup
[Rires]
là je te parle une bague à 4 millions de
dollars donc je te pose on est sur fou
tu es fou amoureux de ta femme tu es
riche ici d'accord tu ne comptes pas tu
es riche ici ta femme
tu n'as aucun problème financier sur
plusieurs génération tu l'offres pas à
ta femme
et puis ensuite bien sûr la plus belle
effectivement il y a peut-être tout un
atelier que ça a fait vivre et qui a
travaillé sur cette bague c'est
uniquement pour ça est-ce que est-ce que
j'aurais aimé aller un tel mariage mais
plutôt crevé et ensuite j'arrête 2
secondes tu n'es pas sur la liste non je
revérifie je revérifier non et je trouve
que de la part de lui c'est manquer des
gars par rapport à Jennifer Garner qui a
toujours été une femme formidable qui
est d'ailleurs qui était invité qui
n'est pas venu comme le frère de Ben
Affleck d'ailleurs casé et je trouve que
c'est un tout petit peu ostentatoire par
rapport aux trois gosses qu'il a eu avec
Isa c'est comme dans TPMP et c'est pour
ça que je t'aime elle dit toujours un
truc mais avec le mauvais côté du truc
il y a pas choqué et à balance surtout
le donc effectivement parce que ça fait
vivre des gens je vois pas pourquoi et
qui on est pour être choqué pas choqué
la meuf elle aurait voulu mettre 100
millions dans son mariage
mais mais qui sommes-nous on est la voix
de la descente et la voix de la raison
de la sagesse on personne moi je vois
juste alors évidemment comme disait pour
ceux qui restent sur le côté que ce soit
Marc Anthony son ex-mari ou encore
jennifer Garner oui on peut avoir les
boules de dire pendant 20 ans en
fait l'un et l'autre il n'arrêtait pas
de penser à l'autre et là mais à un
moment donné on sait pas ce qu'elle a
morflé quand il a abandonné quand il a
rompu leur fiançailles à 20 ans moi je
trouve que c'est une histoire d'amour
qui est merveilleuse je trouve que c'est
un conte de fée du réserve et j'aime
qu'est-ce qu'on a pour vous le problème
c'est que tous ceux qui étaient là
mettent des monnaie tout devait signer
un papier comme quoi de confidentialité
parce que tout a été vendu à des
magazines vogue et tout pour récupérer
un petit peu d'argent mais ils avaient
autorisé les téléphones grosse erreur et
là il y a une enquête en ce moment en
interne dans la famille je vous jure que
c'est vrai parce que le site le fameux
site MTZ qui est le plus célèbre qui le
plus célèbre aux États-Unis je mets dans
le sens que je veux quand tu seras
animatrice
comme ça tu vois et ben le site
américain justement il y a quelqu'un qui
pendant la cérémonie a pris jilo quand
elle chantait et elle sentait pas
n'importe quelle chanson elle chantait
une chanson qu'elle avait réécrite avec
ses propres mots pour son mari donc
c'était il dit la vidéo est sortie
Guillaume hystérique voilà la vidéo et
actuellement on cherche le coupable
et ben cette vidéo est le nom du
coupable dans un instant
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous comme chaque
samedi
c'est la première très heureux de vous
retrouver
merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire
à qui va à Cyril d'abord renouveler
l'émission
et tout ça c'est génial d'avoir tous ces
fans Mathieu d'abord j'ai Stéphane
d'abord
cette première semaine donc ça nous
pousse aussi c'est formidable
on parlait du mariage Jennifer Lopez
Lopez Ben Affleck et je vous avais dit
qu'effectivement ils avaient signé tous
des contrats tu peux t'appeler mademona
tu signes un contrat et effectivement si
avec ton téléphone tu prends une photo
et qu'elle sort quelque part et tu perds
des millions par contre à États-Unis ça
rigole pas donc voilà et elle avait
chanté une chanson et la chanson en fait
qu'elle a chanté c'est elle a repris une
chanson de de de qui de Sean Paul voilà
I'm sine in love with you et à la
chanter à la changer les paroles pour
Ben donc c'était totalement inédit et ça
a été volé et mis sur un site regarder
qui a fait ça
[Musique]
tous les invités sont en train d'essayer
de trouver alors elle a mis son pote
Matt Damon sur le coup pour le moment et
là ils sont en train d'avoir décidé de
voir s'il y avait des caméras et des
photographes il y a des photographes qui
reprennent toutes les photos du mariage
pour voir qui à ce moment-là avait son
téléphone portable
d'accord toi tu crois que lui c'est un
garde du corps
avec le temps vraiment que Ben Affleck
et Jennifer Lopez ils sont place des
places
j'ai une petite anecdote que je vous
raconte à laquée personnelle c'est
l'intéresse quelqu'un c'était au Bon
Marché c'est un magasin parisien au cœur
de Paris
il y a pas longtemps et j'étais avec moi
mon ami enfin un ami et on marche comme
ça et je vois devant moi et je reconnais
de dos Vanessa Paradis Lili Depp je les
vois de dos tu vois elle se dirige vers
un truc aberrant de poils
pour acheter des poils de cuisine moi je
n'ai rien à mais je vais vers les
poils tu vois je commence à regarder un
peu les poils tout ça et je les vois de
face toutes les deux et j'ai vu la
vendeuse qui me dit mais vous n'imaginez
pas dans les grands magasins au mois
d'août toutes les stars américaines
qu'on croise parce que Paris est vide et
elles viennent voilà je les ai encore je
les ai croisés j'ai eu l'élégance de pas
leur parler évidemment mais je pense que
vous en avez très envie